事儿的话我怎么看啊，就看你对她还有没有爱，还有没有感情，你对她要是没有了爱，没有了感情，这日子也好过。我就抱公公婆婆的大腿，我就在公公婆婆面前感恩公公婆婆对我们娘儿仨儿这么好，感恩公公婆婆给我们娘儿三一个退路，给我们娘儿仨一个保障，我就是扮演一个可怜人的这个角色，就是你儿子又欺负我了，哎呀，都怪我没本事，就这那的啊，但是我摊上了一个好的公公婆婆，我就抱公公的大腿，我这边是结婚9年，有一对龙凤胎，6岁这几年期间她一直在床婚是，但是我没有任何实质性分级，就是从手机上面找到的，去年的时候我是在酒店里面直接就报了勾，我报的是卖那个那个，嗯，里那个室友报的勾叔叔也介入了，当时呢，出具了那个调解书，因为我进去揍了那个女的，女生的头被我爸出血了，还缝针了，然后出具了调解，然后也调解了，非常的浪费。再后来我们签了那个婚礼协议嘛，我和我丈夫，但那个协议里边儿主要约定的是房产的问题，但是他那个协议没有公证，也没有落户房产，没有去过户啊什么的，呃，那个房产是登记在男方名下是吗？嗯。
对，是婚前买的还是婚后买的，是属于男方他爸爸给他的，是婚前买的还是婚后买的，就有婚后的，也有婚前他爸爸开发的，然后在婚后转移登记在他名下的，那你是约定那个房产归你吗？还是怎么的，那约定的是他所有的名下的东西都有我一半，只是约定了，但没有公证，是不是对没有公证，你那个约定是谁给你起草的，当时找了一个法律公司帮我起草的，你再说啊，你遇到啥问题了，后来呢，就是我就搬出来了嘛，他父亲就是又买了一套房子，就相当于说因为他儿子这件事情，然后呢，就买了一套房子，写了我和两个孩子的名字，多少钱啊，这房子，这房子130左右，全款的吗？全款然后加上装修的话，大概180都装修好了，是吧，对，只是没有买家具，当时说的是装修好让我们搬出去住，但是现在他们就是说因为我怎么怎么样，所以就是找各种借口，然后就让搬过去，就是分开住嘛，因为我们一直跟老人住在一起，然后就没有买家具。再后来我又发现他过年期间还带着那个女的去跟他的亲戚一起吃饭。
所以我现在就想跟他分开，分开的话我本来想跟他协商的，但是他们一直在拖着我，我协商的就是说我只要这个补偿的房子，还有就是在另外给我50W，然后让我买家具，到时候孩子来找我住啊，或者怎么样啊，最起码孩子有一个地方落脚嘛，然后他们就不同意，就想拖着我，不想跟我分开，现在的话我就是想问一下，就是这个婚内协议当中约定的有十套商品房，那个商品房呢，大概一套价值在200W左右，10套能用2000，我们约定的是一半的话，那就是有1000。在这边他有一个问题，就是我丈夫他爸爸婚前开发的那个房子，当时是在婚后登记在我老公单独所有名下的，并且他们在我怀孕的时候让我签了10份，放弃该房子的共有权，就是他们是在我怀孕的时候让我签这个字的，相当于就是说如果我不签的话，那我怀着两个宝宝，我不签就分开签的话，那就不要打这个房子的主意，他们当时是这样，那我只能签了，因为我舍不得这个孩子嘛，现在那个协议里面约定的就是10份当中有一半是我的，但是又。
牵扯到没有过户，又牵扯到这是婚前的我丈夫她爸爸开发的房子，但是是在婚后落在我丈夫名下单独所有，假如说我起诉的话，我能分到多少，以现行的这个司法解释来看的话，可能比较难哦，就相当于是什么呢啊，没有真正的办理过户，没有真正的做房产的登记，就相当于是什么呢？夫妻财产约定书的法律效力打了折扣了，你们签的这个啊，如果把它认为是夫妻财产约定书的话，有的可打，但是如果把它认为是一种赠与行为的话，又没有办过户，赠与没有实际到位，然后你又没有出过钱，可能大概率讲，以我的个人的这种经验来判断你现在的司法环境来判断你的这个事情呢，确实存在一定的争议，它的争议就在于夫妻财产约定书的效力和赠与协议的效力，就是把它认定为夫妻财产约定书，这个效力和现有的司法解释的话，它会产生一定的力量角逐。现有的司法解释，它就得看钱是谁出的，就得看谁对这个房子的贡献大，就得看这个房子现在值多少钱，就得看你们结婚多长时间了，就得看有没有孩子了。你要说想分1000万的话，这种可能性非常小，但你要说分一定的补偿的话，是有可能的。其实我什么都不要，我想跟看。
他们就是好聚好散，但是他们想拖着我，我也没办法，而且你的那个房子啊，登记在你和两个孩子名下那个房子哦，那个房子也会存在一定的争议，为什么呢？因为没有白纸黑字的写下来是赠与给你单独所有吗？所以那套房子还是婚内的家庭的共同财产嘛，这是其一，其二的话，他们出的这个钱没有白纸黑字落下来是赠与，就有可能搞成借款，嗯，这样当然对我们女生来说肯定是很不利的啊，所以你心理预期也不要那么高，就如果说能够做下来有一个协议，协议什么呢？就是这套房子写在你和两个孩子名下的这套房子，比如说我承诺孩子18岁了之后，我把这个房子过户到孩子名下，我只需要居住权就可以了，可能你能保住这套房，要不然的话，你连这套房子很难保住，怪不得他们现在就说，那在要起诉你就起诉去代夫，因为现在这个司法解释就是规定的话，特别保护财产是怎么来的，首先是怎么来的，特别保护这个点你知道吧，甚至于哪怕说这10套房都登记在你的名下了，就这事儿的话，都没有那么好使，没有原来那么好使，除非你俩去公证处去办公证，说这10套房全都登记到你名下，完了之后你再去办一套公证，这。
10套房你占多少这玩意儿才好使，否则的话，现在就是看钱谁出的，谁对房子的贡献，大房子登记在谁的名下，这件事情已经被弱化了，而且你们俩光签那个协议，又没有办过户，又没有办公证，也被弱化了，对他现在就是可能是他的问题，然后现在就是搞得我离他也不是，然后留下也不是，然后他直接还跟我说，让我搞清楚自己的身份和定位，能让就让，不能让就滚。他直接这样跟我说，这事儿的话，我怎么看啊，就看你对他还有没有爱，还有没有感情，你对他要是没有了爱，没有了感情，这日子也好过。我就抱公公婆婆的大腿，我就在公公婆婆面前感恩公公婆婆对我们娘儿仨儿这么好，感恩公公婆婆给我们娘儿仨一个退路，给我们娘儿仨儿一个保障，我就是扮演一个可怜人的这个角色，就是你儿子又欺负我了，哎呀，都怪我没本事，就这那的啊，但是我摊上了一个好的公公婆婆，我就抱公公的大腿，假如说丈夫靠不住，靠老人，我觉得哪怕有一天能靠我都不想分开，就是都靠不了，就是从结婚的时候就开始帮着我，然后他们把所有的事情都推在我身上，但是我跟你讲啊，该说不说，作为有钱人，房产儿媳妇儿，这是属于常态。
正常去操作，作为有钱人，你说2000万的房产过户，给儿子，要求儿媳妇签一个书面的东西，这是属于常态，正常，但是我感觉人家能给你买一套130的房，然后装修，装了50万，花了180万，登记在你和孩子名下，人家也还是可以的，没有到那种说一毛不拔，没有到那种赶尽杀绝的程度，但是他们现在就是不买家具，就是不让我们搬过去，不买家具自己也可以买呀，你没必要买很好的家具啊，就买个床，买点锅碗瓢盆就能过呀这日子，这呀，对呀，你上来你还想买什么两三万的床吗？不需要2000也能买个床，真的，我感觉就这事儿，如果你想要分开过的话，你要拿出态度也行，嫁给他，我这边的所有东西都是我父母给我的，就是没有靠他家任何，你父户条件很好，是不是就是都是此组相当的好，那你早说呀，如果说你父母条件这么好的话，你是独生女吗？不是，我是重组家庭，就是家庭比他家差，就是这一点，你重组家庭谁跟他们家旗鼓相当，是你亲爹还是你亲妈，还是继父还是继母，继父继父跟他家旗鼓相当，嗯，对，那不是一回事儿，对，只是说在经济方面我没有靠过他家任何，就是我就是自己养。
自己或者是娘家还要倒贴来养我，这一方面只是说小孩子确实是他们在出的力比较多，养育方面小孩子他们在养，这个是真的，但是我这边他们是一毛钱都不会花在我身上的，所以我现在就很难，我觉得我才30，然后这样耗在这种，主要是我丈夫他没有本事，什么都是靠家里边儿，我最起码我这边自己有一份稳定的工作什么的，我丈夫他是比较听他家里的话，包括我，我丈夫他爸爸，他一个人要养家里面的9个人，所以他爸爸是不会再分多余的钱去养我的，所以其实我就是人也靠不住，钱也拿不到，在这个家庭里边，我就觉得我跟他分开，我自己过得会更好，只是小孩子会比较可怜，所以我现在就很为难，那你想问我的问题是什么呢？就是刚才我跟你讲了啊，你们有这个协议，说2000万的房产能分到多少，这个很难讲，分1000万的可能性几乎不存在，不太可能，我不分1000万，就分个家具的钱就行了，我我带着孩子去那边住，然后你的那套房啊，登记在你和孩子名下，那套房啊也存在风险，第一这套房大概率下是夫妻共同的财产，第二，这套房大概率下可能还会涉及到债务问题，对。
他们他爸爸说是跟家里面的亲戚借钱买的，现在就这样跟我说就这意思啊，所以呢，如果要分开的话，可能我们的心理预期得调整，假设我们分不到什么钱，因为你你老公没有钱嘛，是吧，他没有钱给你嘛，假设分不到什么钱的话，还走不走这一步，走真的想走了，我现在已经把我妈拉黑了，我妈直接就一直在那里滴滴，滴滴嘀的，然后我受不了，我直接把他拉黑了，我不想让他影响我，我也不想影响他，那你要花钱请一个厉害一点的律师，或许能给你打一个翻身仗，因为你的这种情况，他确实在实践当中，他存在很大的争议，如果把这个事儿认定为是夫妻财产约定书的话，有的可打，之前我咨询过有一个方案，就是说先打这个协议，就是先在婚内打这个协议，不打分开，先打协议这个比较好，还是说直接打分开，然后连着分割一起打，哪一种比较好一点？如果你确定不想跟人家过了啊，一点都不想过了，他说先打这个协议，不打分开的意思是什么呢？就是说这个协议打出来了，如果说你分不到钱，你就别离异，他是这个意思呗，但是你都不想跟人家过了，你也不能接受这个不分开的这个结局啊，他的意思就是说打分开的话，时间可能会拖得比较长，打协议的话可能快一点，也有道理，也可以。
然后再加上就是我有他的那个流水嘛，她一年不到给外面那个女生花了20个W左右，但是她给我转账，我带着孩子，她给我转账就是两三百，两三百这种，然后我就觉得好搞笑，那现在如果孩子跟着你住那个新房子的话，谁带孩子呢？因为我要上班嘛，然后我家这边其实娘家这边也靠不住，说白了只是说车子房子他们也都给我添置了，就是我有自己的车和房，孩子的话就是只能说是靠婆家这边要多一点，但是我的话我可以就是下班去接，因为他们现在也面临要上小学了嘛，行，那好，那你还有什么要问我的吗？还有一点就是我们现在就是三代人住在一起的那个房子，还有一套房子嘛，三代人住的那套房是法拍房，那值400W左右，是由我丈夫他爸爸出资，以我丈夫个人的名义在那个平台上拍下的法拍房，房本上写的是我老公单独的名字，在去年我发现他出车这件事情以后，我老公他未经过我同意，把这套房子就过户转移到了那个我丈夫他爸爸的名下，就花了20W过户了嘛。假如说我起诉这个婚内。
给议的话，可不可以以这个理由去起诉，如果说他爸爸能证明这400万都是他爸爸出的钱，然后只是借用他儿子的名义去买了这个房，买下来了之后又转给了他爸爸，这个是没毛病的，相当于是什么关系呢？我借用我儿子的名义，让我儿子帮我代持了一个资产，这么个关系，钱如果全都是他爸爸出的，有这个证据在的话，他们这个是能走通的，就是我可以从这一点，相当于这个是属于我们婚后的财产，即使是你出资的，也属于赠与的，是我们婚后赠与的，那我是不是列占婚后的一半，那需要你来证明哦，你手上有赠与的协议吗？有赠与的聊天记录吗？有赠与的这些东西吗？没有的话，那你就证明不了哦，那我真的太被动了，你也不被动，因为你没出钱呀，这个钱确实是人家爸爸出的呀，但是我是从初中就跟他在一起了，然后我们两个认识18年，感觉所谓的成功成本太大了，有点不甘心，那别的还有什么要问我的吗？还有一点，那假如说这些东西可能他说的风险较大的情况下，那我就直接律师都不用找了，直接先起诉离婚就行了，反正我也不想分手么，也可以直接起诉离婚，然后到时候分财产的时候把你那个。
协议拿出来看法官怎么认定好那就好，因为我看他起诉的话，如果要加上这些东西的话，那个费用会比较高。第一把起诉的时候不要提我有多少财产要分，第一把起诉的时候就是起诉判我们离异，第二合法分割共同财产，这样的话你的诉讼费只需要交几十块钱判离，然后合法分割共同，对是的好刑起诉状上面就围绕这两方面写就行了，是吧？啊，当然还涉及到孩子，就是说孩子归谁呀，孩子的话就先把一人一个吧，可以啊，到时候再协商好，那就这样啊，你们以后打那个离婚官司啊，第一把的时候都不要具体说我要分多少钱，这样的话诉讼费便宜一点，因为诉讼费是按照你要分多少钱来算的，你要主张多少钱来算的，我们但凡是有点经验的，我们第一把打的时候就是说依法分割共同财产，我不说我有多少钱要分，我告诉你啊，有一个窍门，如果法官让你去补诉讼费，就表示什么他要判离，如果他不判离的话，就不会要求你补诉讼费，理解吧，这个是一个经验之谈了啊，记得点赞关注哦。